is now time to get ready for the
rockabilly festival all right get your
50s inspired outfits and classic cars
out the viva las vegas rockabilly
weekend is back at the orleans excuse me
i'm joking i spoke to event creator tom
ingram to find out what we can expect
this year
tom welcome to las vegas now
thank you it's good to be here we are so
excited for what you're going to tell us
about but first i have to ask you since
it's definitely on topic are those
records behind you yes records and cds
of course because you are the king of
viva las vegas so let's talk music let's
talk the festival what can we expect
tell us what it is
it's the four days of non-stop
1950s style music with bands djs for
less performers
plus there's the car show with every car
that's been built before 1964.
whoa okay so how long has it been going
on
when is it where is it
that used to be a simple question to
answer because you know we didn't miss a
year before but this is the 24th year
the 24th year so why do you keep why did
you choose to bring this to las vegas
uh i used to organize a similar sort of
event in britain but much much smaller
and then when i moved to california
i i wanted to do the same sort of event
but
it wasn't going to work in california
because all the bars closed too early
so when i realized that vegas was 24
hours i thought that's the place
okay so this is this is a party oh yes
this is a party so what can we expect
this year new and improved
um it's
new is it obviously it everyone's got to
wear a mask and it's almost like two
different events you've got the partying
going on inside the hotel
and then the car show outside and at the
car show yeah the people are standing by
their cars basically for three days
and but one of the big advantages that
we have
is that
at night time we close the parking lot
at 10 o'clock
and every all the cars are locked in
there no cars are allowed to come or go
between 10 pm and 10 am
so the owners can go in back inside the
hotel
have loads to drink call back the hotel
room and not have to worry about
drinking and driving because we won't we
won't let them get their cars not until
10 o'clock in the morning so you thought
of it all you thought of it all so we
love that fun to save fun yes
drinking and driving we love that so
where can people buy tickets and how can
they participate in viva las vegas now
you can just go to the website which is
viva las vegas dot net and just click on
the tickets button and there's the link
there's a link and tell us the date one
more time
it's the september the 9th through the
12th
okay
the big car show day is the saturday
all right cool thank you so much tom
obviously you are so cool so we're
excited to see everybody that's coming
out for this
so am i it's going to be good it's we've
been worried because of obviously the
whole situation whether it's going to go
ahead or not but it is it is it is all
right well viva las vegas time we'll see
you soon okay thanks a lot
thank you viva las vegas rockabilly
weekend for sponsoring that segment
catching september 9th through the 12th
at the orleans for more information just
visit vivalasvegas.net